prime minister the police have announced
another 50 fines you again your wife
uh no but as soon as you have more to
say about that sam as i've said to you
many times before as you know you you
will be amongst the very first to know
100 fines is quite something it wasn't
that long ago five months that you said
no rules were ever broken what do you
say to people who find it difficult to
believe that you ever really thought
this was true well as soon as i have any
more to say about that sam you will be
amongst the very first to know but what
we're doing here in sorry stoke if i
could just stay on this camera
our questions prime minister uh
kierstarma has said that he will resign
if he's found guilty of breaking the law
why do you think he did that is it
evidence of honor
look as soon as i have any more to say
on this on this subject i will make sure
that you sam are amongst the very first
today but what we're doing here in stoke
is making sure that we focus on the
thing i think that matters uh most to
the people of this country right now and
that is getting us through the postcoded
aftershocks making sure that we not only
help people with
the cost of living right now
with all the things that we're doing and
continue to apply maximum ingenuity to
to dealing with it but also take the
steps
that are necessary to deal with some of
the supply side problems particularly on
cost of energy
cost of housing uh cost of transport uh
cost of child care and look at what
we're doing in the in the queen speech
and beyond and you've got the the bills
that are going to be necessary uh to
help us through it and
so the british energy security strategy
is is there to help particularly uh with
the uh
our basic strategic failure over the
last few decades to make sure that we
have dependable uh resources ourselves
i've just been to a fantastic business
uh here in stoke where they are growing
uh they're putting on sales around
europe uh but they they're hiring more
and more people
but they need to have secure dependable
energy supplies that's why we're having
a nuclear reactor every year that's why
we're going into 50 gigawatts of wind by
2030. that promise that was a queen
speech on tuesday but what are you going
to do next there are array of options
that you could reach for what do you
think of income tax cuts a windfall tax
getting rid of grade levies and do you
think that we need help as some of your
mp say that's basically on the scale of
the covered rescue package which are
those options are you leaning towards
alright so we will continue to use all
the ingenuity uh and uh
compassion that we showed during the the
kobe pandemic and what we're already
doing as you know is helping people with
the cost of
of energy
9.1 billion pound package to help people
right now uh 22 billion pounds
altogether
helping local councils to support
families that are in particular hardship
but the crucial thing that we're doing
is making sure that we steer the economy
through the
uh the post covered aftershocks
with continued uh high-wage high skill
employment and that has been the real
miracle of the uk economy uh in the in
the post-copy period the biggest plunge
in output for 300 years uh people
thought we would now have him
unemployment running at about 12 or 14
actually it's right down to 3.8
uh youth unemployment is at uh at or
near record lows and that is a is a
crucial thing so what we're focused on
everything we're doing now is focused on
continuing to deliver jobs and growth
that is the best way to power through
the difficult times now caused by
global inflation in the cost of energy
that will eventually
come down that will eventually abate so
we've got to deal with we've got to help
people right now with all sorts of
things and i've mentioned some of them
but what we've also got to do is fix the
underlying uh supply side issues but
more help prime minister we're expecting
a statement potentially even before the
summer when rishi soon that's going to
have to open his purse strings can you
give us a sense of what you think needs
to be done so july for instance what
what's already happening we know what's
already happening
in the pipeline in july
there is going to be the the tax cut for
everybody on or 70 of people on national
insurance uh that's probably worth about
330 pounds uh you've already seen the
cuts in uh in council tax uh we will do
uh things to help people in the in the
short term of course and i'm not going
to
anticipate anything more with that we
may do but the crucial thing is to make
sure that we have uh the strong uh
employment uh situation because that is
the key thing you you remember the
economic uh crises of the 80s or the 90s
and what was so harrowing about those
times well i remember being so utterly
miserable was millions of people
who were on the economic scrap people
who told who were told that they
couldn't get jobs that was a terrible
time for our country we've got in many
ways the opposite of that situation now
business i've just been in uh here in
here in stoke they're looking for
for labor they're looking for high skill
people to come now the job of government
that our job right now is to help the
help those businesses to find the people
they need to skill up
people in this country which is what our
queen speech does
but also to make sure that they have the
dependable
energy supplies that they need that is
absolutely vital prime minister people
in work are still also having to go to
for instance food banks your mp lee
anderson said that food banks have grown
in part because people are hooked on
ready meals not prepared to cook for
themselves what do you make of those
comments we've got to support people who
are finding it tough uh in any way that
we can and i've said some of the things
that we're doing but when it comes to
supporting uh
people who
who need
food for instance and families who are
facing particular hardship uh we we've
given extra money to councils and we'll
continue to do that you know about the
holidays and uh an activities fund that
uh that we've been supporting 200
million pounds worth of
support for uh for people who uh who you
know whose kids are going without meals
we can't have that we we don't i we we
don't want to see any
kid any family going hungry in this
country and we will do whatever we can
to help
is lee anderson right to say that people
are using food banks because they can't
cook the best answer
for the problems of uh of kids going
hungry which is in my view totally
unacceptable of families uh not able to
get the uh the meals any we is to do all
the support that we're we're giving and
and
as i've said we will use maximum
ingenuity and compassion throughout this
period as we as we come out as we come
through the postcode
aftershocks but also continue with our
focus on high-wage high skill
jobs that is the thing that is is really
going to take this country forward
northern ireland prime minister
can you just set out what you think is
needed do you think the text for
instance of the protocol needs to change
is that a precondition
uh for sorting this out or could there
be a solution that we negotiate with the
european union that leaves that original
text the same but just changes the way
that the eu implemented look northern
ireland is
an incredible place got a fantastic
future at the moment very sadly the
institutions of uh democracy the the
political governance of northern ireland
has collapsed uh the institutions set up
under the belfast good friday agreement
aren't functioning
the executive
the assembly they can't form
that's a bad thing at any time
it's a bad thing now when the people of
northern ireland need
leadership they need a government a
regional provincial government will
focus
on cost of living on health care
on transport on the things that matter
in their everyday lives
they haven't got that that's a real real
problem now the reason they don't have
that is because there's one community in
northern ireland uh that won't accept
the way the protocol works at present
we've got to fix that um but do you need
to change the wording of the protocol to
get a solution we need to get the
executive we need to get the government
of northern ireland up and running
and that's and that's vital and so no
not at all so it follows uh since the
uh it's clear that
the
unionist community
won't accept the protocol that's i'm
afraid of obvious from the from what has
happened uh we've got to fix it and we
will have to final question for the pool
what's your response to allegations in
the new york times that a conservative
party took donations from madonna with
links to russia
uh
i could believe and money linked to a
russian bank account
all
all our donations are registered in the
normal way and
uh you you to give donations to a
political party in this country uh
you've got to be from the uk
well let's rejoin our deputy political
editor sam coats in stoke sam as ever
with these interviews time is short but
the list of things to talk about is very
very long a lot crammed in there what
were your main takeaways from what the
prime minister had to say
well sarah jane
in these interviews any number of
different boris johnsons can turn up
sometimes you get repentant boris
johnson sometimes you get enthusiastic
boris johnson today we got campaigning
disciplined boris johnson who didn't
want to give a quarter despite the
frankly pretty atrocious uh headlines
that weren't uh sort of programmed in
for today uh all generated by the
metropolitan police uh because of the
announcement that they have doubled the
number of fines that have been levied to
people in dennis street in the center of
government as a result of party gate
time and time again i asked him what do
you think about it what's your reaction
to kierstama uh
promising to resign
yet uh boris johnson simply said that if
he had more to say he would uh
come back to parliament come to the
media and say it in future not wanting
to no it's a gamble to not show any
contrition it's a gamble essentially to
dead back that subject
i think that the conservatives over the
last few weeks have been uh trying to
turn the spotlight on to kierstama uh he
has now pledged of course to resign if
durham police in the next six to eight
weeks find him guilty uh of having
broken coven rules now there is a
renewed focus particularly after day
today on boris johnson he is trying to
simply make that a question for the
future by saying he's going to wait
until all of the police investigations
have wrapped up and that could still be
some time i understand because
questionnaires still going out last week
uh and interviews still going on
and then of course there'll be the
report by the uh civil servant sue gray
and only then will he really account for
himself so basically boris johnson's
saying on that i'm not going to talk
about it today and he hopes that that
line will hold in his hopes uh that he
won't endure too much criticism from his
party on that on everything else again
it was more of a campaigning tone where
he was unwilling uh to give
many details of the quest of the
question many answers frankly to the
questions uh that we were asking typical
boris he gave a smorgasbord of different
references to things in the queen's
speech initiatives that this
government's doing we had nuclear power
stations we had regional government we
had the whole lot frankly but not really
much detail on what he thought about lee
anderson's comments about food banks uh
what he thought should be done before
the summer to help people with the cost
of living crisis that hasn't already
been announced what should happen to the
northern ireland protocol whether or not
it should be uh junked uh the actual
cortex should be junked or there's a
solution outside of that so all of those
main questions all those questions
aren't answered lots of words from the
prime minister otherwise however sarah j